concluido la jornada electoral aquí en
marruecos una jornada electoral marcada
por la baja participación que apenas
rozó el 40 por ciento lo que demuestra
la falta de interés y desconfianza en
los partidos políticos en un sistema
donde el rey sigue teniendo alto poder
ejecutivo aún no conocemos a los
resultados y los sondeos están
prohibidos pero la mayoría de analistas
auguran una posible parcial victoria en
número de votos para el partido de la
justicia y el desarrollo la formación
islamista que tiene la presidencia del
gobierno desde 2011 pero los análisis
también apuntan hacia un retroceso de
esta formación sobre todo si se tiene en
cuenta el descontento popular las
divisiones internas y también la ley
electoral y es que por primera vez se
eliminó la barrera del 3% para obtener
escaños y se modificó la forma de
calcular el cociente electoral y lo que
favorece a los partidos minoritarios en
este sentido también los análisis
apuntan a un posible crecimiento de los
liberales del partido de la autenticidad
y la modernidad y sobre del
reagrupamiento nacional de
independientes partido también liberal
que lidera al actual ministro de
agricultura así como yo quiero además es
el empresario más adinerado del país y
por otra parte observadores de los
principales partidos políticos han
denunciado irregularidades en algunos
colegios electorales denuncian a la
presencia de intermediarios que dicen a
estarían comprando votos e incluso
transportando a los votantes pero hasta
el momento no trascendió a ninguna
investigación